I've been a prostitute
for eight years.
- Eight years?
- Mm-hmm.
- I guess you love your work.
- Yeah, baby.
I am definitely looking
forward to this.
- Oh, you're gonna love it.
- Yeah.
(Forrest, voice-over)
My Mile High Club membership
- was finally on track.
- [pings]
(woman)
The captain has turned off
the fasten seatbelt sign.
(Forrest, voice-over)
But then I hit some bizarre
and unexpected turbulence.
- How much is he paying you?
- $200 plus the ticket.
I'll give you $300
if I can go first.
Oh, sorry, excuse me.
Just mind your own business.
- Thank you.
- Uh, sold.
(Forrest, voice-over)
Incredibly enough I had
stumbled onto a flight
full of recovering sex addicts
on an immersion therapy trip
- to a Tijuana brothel.
- $350 if I get to go first.
- Yup, come on.
- What?
$400 plus 10,000
frequent flier miles.
(Forrest, voice-over)
And the line for immersion
was long.
Take note,
this is apparently
one of the things
that can happen
when you are so determined
to have sex on an airplane
then you hire a prostitute
to travel with you.
This extraordinary,
and horrifying, development
led to a truly disgusting
turn of events.
Though my prostitute,
Margaret, did earn enough money
to self-publish
her book of poetry.
- Finally.
- [pings]
(man)
The captain has turned on
the fasten seatbelt sign.
(Forrest)
What are you doing?
- We gotta sit down.
- What? Why?
You can't be standing
when the seatbelt light is on.
No, no, no, no.
You gotta be kidding me.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
This is gonna take, like,
one or two minutes. Please.
- We gotta go back there.
- No. No.
I have to join
the Mile High Club right now.
Well, okay, but I have
to have my seatbelt on.
It's okay.
Listen, here.
Put the little blanket on.
And do it right here
in the seat?
- Yeah.
(man) Flight Attendants will be
coming through the cabin
to collect any remaining
- service items.
- Uh, you better hurry.
Yeah, okay, fine.
[metal jingles, zipper unzips]
(Forrest, voice-over)
I was, eventually,
allowed entry
into the Mile High Club,
but so what?
As it turned out
any idiot was free to join.
I learned that I prefer
my sexual encounters
to be both free
and free of spectators.
[sighs]
[cries]
I also learned the only belt
I want to unbuckle
to have sex
is my pant's belt.
And, perhaps also,
my heart's belt.
No matter how scary
the turbulence.
Joining the Mile High Club,
three stars.
I can't believe
it didn't work out
between you and shampoo.
I mean, you treated her
horribly,
but who knew she'd have
so much self-respect?
There was no way
of editing that...
that didn't make it
seem horrifying.